cette maille ou un accident de
trottinette sur la voie publique et
présente un traumatisme
une équipe de la croix rouge intervient
pour pouvoir l'amener à l'hôpital dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
pas de blessés ceci n'est qu'un exercice
une démonstration pour aguerrir le
public on a saoulé des protocoles et des
procédures qui nous permettent justement
d'assurer l'état de la victime surtout
d'éviter toute aggravation car notre
rôle premier est d'assurer les premiers
secours mais surtout de la transporter
dans les meilleures conditions
donc c'est vrai que ça peut paraître un
peu procédurier mais c'est justement
pour les tables habitants le
défibrillateur c'est quoi peut-être
machine vous en trouvez dans énormément
d'endroits publics fait indiquée par ce
symbole utilisation d'un défibrillateur
technique du massage cardiaque parfois
même en réalité virtuelle
toute la journée la croix-rouge organisé
des formations gratuites toutes ont été
complètes
donc notre rôle d'auxiliaire d'état
c'est de former le grand public à savoir
quels gestes faire pour ce laps de temps
ce maillon de la chaîne de l'urgence un
événement qui s'adressait à tous les
publics de tous les âges pour
sensibiliser le plus de monde possible
si on sait ce qu'il faut faire ça va
très vite
ça peut permettre de sauver quelqu'un
plutôt que de rester à côté ou passer à
côté il ya pas mais je sais pas faire je
m'en vais
non c'est très utile objectifs à
atteindre pour la croix rouge française
une personne formée aux gestes de
premiers secours par foyer